their top story at four new regulations
will soon kick in for short-term rentals
here in clark county that's right
commissioners voted to approve those new
regulations just yesterday outlining
where they can go and how many are
allowed still a lot of questions however
concerning this topic joe moeller spoke
to people in the industry about their
concerns he's live now near decatur and
desert inn joe
definitely a lot of questions come next
year there will be 3 000 legally
operating short-term rentals such as
airbnb's here in clark county but some
experts say there's a lot more than that
already in operation and now they have
concerns about how exactly this will all
play out
people that want to come vacation here
it's an industry where some people make
a lot of money obviously las vegas is a
huge destination derrick mullinger is
the owner of ice realty right now people
are really confused they don't know what
the law is what the law isn't how
they're going to get their places to be
legally compliant tuesday the county
approved new regulations with a number
of rules including one license per
person max occupancy is two people per
bedroom or 10 people a unit and a
minimum of two night stays the other big
role is short term rentals must be one
thousand feet from another he estimates
there are around 12 thousand short term
rentals operating in the county but the
county is only permitting three thousand
of them an average family home that's
three bed two bath that i can get
eighteen hundred dollars a month for and
i was getting ten thousand a month in
airbnb my profit margin is over the
county plans to step up enforcement as
well the fact that we're trying to
actually legalize something and get our
hands around it is really the most
important part county commissioner tick
sigerblum says there will be a 24-hour
phone number for people to report issues
we're going to hire new code enforcement
officers who could actually be go out
when we get a complaint for a long time
it was illegal in las vegas proper right
so but people still did it anyway joel
just is the ceo of camco they operate
hoas across the valley he says they are
having to look into how to regulate this
moving forward we do have attorneys that
represent the associations and they're
looking at
what are the responsibilities of the
h.o.a
back out here live mullinger says he
also thinks a lot more reporting will
happen from one airbnb host to another
the application process for this all
starts in september and these rules and
regulations don't go into place until
next spring reporting live near decatur
ndi joe mohler live local now thank you